qué tal Andrés Muy buenas tardes en
efecto pues a esta hora ya se ha
confirmado como bien lo decía por parte
del Ministerio Público y de Medicina
forense el fallecimiento de cuarenta y
un detenidas
Esa es la cifra hasta el momento
confirmada en cuanto al número de
reclusas heridas todavía no hay un dato
específico pero sí se tiene evidencia de
que algunas de ellas han sido
trasladadas en estado de gravedad a uno
de los principales centros asistenciales
aquí en Tegucigalpa la capital Mientras
que otras reclusas con heridas menores
están siendo atendidas en carpas que han
sido instaladas en las afueras de la
cárcel que en este momento se encuentra
intervenida por las autoridades del
Ministerio de seguridad y de la junta
interventor interventora que fue
nombrada el pasado mes de abril por la
presidenta
xi omara Castro todavía no hay un número
específico de reclusas heridas el saldo
que sí se maneja de fallecidas como bien
lo decías es de 41 hasta esta hora del
día Kenia se sabe también Que varios
enfrentamientos y tiroteos se han
presentado en varias cárceles del país
desde abril A qué se debe esta situación
Pues según lo manifestaba la
viceministra de seguridad que a su vez
es la presidenta de esta junta
interventora se debe a una respuesta del
crimen organizado luego de que se han
intervenido las principales cárceles de
máxima seguridad y se ha privado a los
reos de algunas de las prebendas que
tenían por ejemplo el cortarle las
medidas de comunicación con teléfonos
celulares además se han incautado muchas
armas se han encontrado sitios
escondidos en estas cárceles donde
tenían escondidas armas de fuego y algún
otro tipo de armas Entonces lo decía
esta tarde la viceministra es una
respuesta precisamente a eso mientras
que la presidenta Castro fue mucho más
allá diciendo que este había sido un
ataque directo de las maras y pandillas
muchos de estos privados de libertad
están en los principales cárceles del
país